for centuries Wars have been fought over
resources but soon we could be seeing
more fighting over arguably the most
precious resource of all water there are
too few resources for for too many
people and they end up fighting uh with
one another as climate change gets worse
and the planet gets hotter and drier the
fight for water is only going to
intensify
so where could we see water wars and How
likely are they to actually happen
by 2025 the UN predicts two-thirds of
the global population will live in water
scarce areas
five years after that it's thought that
700 million around the world could be at
risk of displacement by water scarcity
there's no gray area here people cannot
live without water so a lack of access
to water pretty much leaves you with two
options either you move somewhere where
there is access or you fight for what's
available
so looking back over the past 50 years
we have yet to see a true water War
typically countries don't go to war over
any one single issue it's usually a
complex mixture of issues that leads
countries to go to war I'm not thinking
that that most water problems or climate
problems if you wish
end up in wars of the conventional sense
of stay Russia versus Ukraine it's it's
more the undermining of the social order
uh that of course uh undermines security
within a country but it can't bleed over
into another neighboring countries or or
even further away in 2018 The Joint
Research Center listed these places as
likely sites for so-called
hydropolitical interactions the Nile
Ganges brahmaputra induce Tigris
Euphrates and Colorado Rivers
here in Sudan where the Niles meet to
form the longest river in the world
violence over water resources is sadly
commonplace ancient Nubian and Egypt
fought over control of the Nile Valley
for centuries and in more recent times
the Scramble for water and arable land
has fueled inter-communal conflict
around the country since 2003 200 000
people have been killed in Darfur on
dafu indeed in many ways we are in a
free fall it's a terrible situation and
a resolution must come soon in the early
2000s fighting broke out between nomadic
herders and sedentary farmers in the dry
dockport region the change in climate of
Sudan meant that groups had to compete
more and more for land and water
the violent rivalry and government
Crackdown killed and displaced hundreds
of thousands of people
scarcity wasn't the sole reason for this
war but it was certainly one of the
major causes of it clashes are ongoing
today land is not good enough if you are
rural communities you need to have water
to make that land valuable so we have
seen there in areas like Sudan like
Darfur where there's been
access to land issues and domination of
land and use of that land
leading to violence between communities
and that is really the concern for the
future that the climate change that is
already happening could be driving these
sort of local conflicts ever more
just beyond the country's borders a
major controversy is brewing over water
now one that has threatened to develop
into a major war
[Music]
Ethiopian Renaissance Dam
it's a huge Hydro power Dam on the Blue
Nile a tributary of the Nile that starts
in Ethiopia
it's estimated to have cost billions of
dollars
and will eventually have a 6 000
megawatt capacity the equivalent to six
nuclear power stations
once fully active it will be the largest
hydroelectric power plant in Africa and
will be a big boost Ethiopia's economy
but it has also heightened political
tension across the region
Egypt relies heavily on the Nile in fact
nearly all of its water comes from the
river
any disturbance to the water level could
have massive consequences in Egypt
something the country is well aware of
this is someone literally someone's
lifeline and this Grand Renaissance dam
is being built across the segment of the
Nile that that feeds Egypt with 85
percent of its water so they're deathly
afraid of this
um and they are doing a lot of saber
rattling even suggesting they're you
know violent conflict could be in the
cards since the first brick was laid
back in 2011 Egypt has tried to stop the
dam being built
at times military conflict has seemed
close
in 2013 senior Egyptian politicians were
caught on camera discussing whether to
destroy the dam
though advisor to the then president
played that down to Sky News it would
not be totally acceptable to talk about
military options when they did not
explore other options as well however
exactly as you said it's a matter of
life for Egypt in 2019 Ethiopian
president ABI Ahmed said No Force could
prevent the country from finishing the
dam
The Filling of that diamond and these
dams are massive Mega projects that take
anywhere between five and ten years to
to fill the dam Reservoir so it's during
this filling stage which has already
started where the greatest potential for
conflict lives so there you might have
some dry years and the flow of the Nile
is going to be naturally reduced and
less water will be allowed to flow
Downstream as Ethiopia's interest will
be to hold as much back to fill the dam
as fast as possible so during the next
few years where the greatest potential
for conflict between Ethiopia and Egypt
really comes to Bear water wars have
been happening for centuries but there's
a big reason why we may be seeing more
in the future climate change
increasing Global temperature scores is
more water to evaporate changing the
water cycle that means more heavy
rainfall in some places and more drought
in others
when we speak with local communities in
different parts of Africa where I work
local farming communities will use the
present tense when they talk about
climate change impacts not the future
they're not talking about a far-off
future where rainfall is going to be
altered they're talking about today and
in some cases at that very local level
we've actually seen that breakout into
armed conflict between these groups as
they're competing from for increasingly
scarce Water Resources but all of this
does not mean water wars are inevitable
in the past countries and communities
have been more likely to cooperate to
tackle any water crises
even at the Nile Dam despite years of
tension it is yet to boil over but
there's no escaping the fact that the
world is getting hotter and drier and
has access to such a vital resource like
water becomes more and more difficult
for people globally they could turn to
more Extreme Measures to secure it
Greater pressures placed on Water
Resources the need for economies to
continue growing but need for cities to
take on board more and more products and
services that are water intensive and of
course climate change changing that
whole scenario that could change things
the future could look different to the
Past